- We're all quarantined
though with our families
so I thought it'd be fun to
see how well we know them,
well at least, y'all.
(laughs)
How well Julie and Emma know each other.
This is our little quarantine family quiz.
(upbeat music)
So basically what y'all are gonna do,
or I'm gonna ask you to do is
I'm gonna read a question
and you each write an answer
and hold the answer up to the camera
so we can see it,
and we're gonna see how many
you can answer the same.
So how well you know each other.
Are you ready?
- Ready.
- Right.
- Okay perfect let's start.
First one, what was Emma's
favorite lullaby as a child?
- Oh, okay.
Right here it is.
This is my, my guess anyway
which was, not a lullaby
- [Kelly] That's mine.
- And mine is backwards right?
I have to turn my camera around.
- My mother sang that to me
and I sing that to my kids,
that's ours, that's amazing.
Okay so, next question, what did Emma
get in the most trouble for as a teenager?
- Easy, easy, easy I think.
Well then there are a lot of
things I didn't know about.
- Well then well done at hiding them Emma.
- This is what I remember
getting grounded for so.
Yep.
- Smoking!
- Not anymore.
There is a lot of other
stuff that I knew about
but didn't know about,
and turned a blind eye to.
- She turned out great.
She turned out great.
- She did and,
- Luckily I didn't stink.
- Okay well next question,
what was Emma's favorite
Julie Andrews movie growing up?
- I have to answer that
verbally, can I do that?
It's too long to write.
I don't know what her
favorite movie was of mine
when she was growing up
and maybe she'll tell you
but I do know what was the one
that upset her the most
and believe it or not
it was The Sound of Music
because she couldn't
bear to see mommy unhappy
by the intermission of the movie.
- I could watch the first
half, not the second half.
- Yes to the end of the
first half, yes of the movie.
And by its intermission
she would say right
I'm going, I'll just
go out and get some tea
or something mummy,
pushing and avoid the scene
of me unhappy so she wouldn't feel sad.
- Yeah I couldn't bear
to see her cry on screen.
- Now what would you have answered Emma?
- This is what I wrote.
(beep)
- Yeah
- Interesting.
- That was a wonderful
movie to make I must say.
- Not many people know about this movie,
it was made in the sixties,
but it is such a beautiful epic saga
about the history of the missionary,
the first missionaries who came to Hawaii.
It's based on a James Michener novel
and mom plays this missionary
and she's married to
- Max von Sydow
- Max von Sydow.
- Who was a joy to work with.
- It's just a beautiful film
and it's and she's.
- It was hot that summer.
It was very, very hard work to make.
It was either the the fire
or the measles epidemic or
the ship at sea or the storm
or I mean, every single,
once we finished one scene
we were on to the next
epic moment you know.
- So I might have loved it
because there's a childbirth scene
and maybe when I was a little I fantasized
that that was what it looked like
when you were giving birth
to me or something, who knows.
- My, my daughter right now is
obsessed with childbirth, she keeps,
she looked at me last night,
I was putting her in her
bed and she said mom,
I have something to tell you.
She's five and she looked at
me and she said I'm pregnant.
And I was like. What!
(laughs)
I was like I'm sorry, where
did you even learn that word
and, and like what?
And I don't know what she was watching
and she said well no you said when you
were pregnant with me I was in your belly
and she just wants
to be in my belly again it's so weird.
- Oh of course
- It kinda still looks
like your there cause mommy
hasn't lost all the weight.
(laughs)
- I love that.
- Okay so here's the next one,
what was Emma's favorite food as a child?
(tick tock click)
Don't wanna hear more excuses Andrews.
[Laughter]
- Let' see. Oh.
- Oh that's my daughters.
(beep)
- The other end of the day mom.
- Okay cinnamon toast, right.
I was wrong then.
- Breakfast more than, I did love dessert,
but breakfast even more.
- Wonderful, what else?
- What was Julie's favorite
drink in the 1970s?
Please tell me it was alcoholic.
- oh you know that Em.
- Am I supposed to know this,
I love that my team wrote this question.
- 1970s, I don't, um okay.
- It takes too long to write it down.
- Okay you can just tell
us, she can write it.
- Well this goes, I'm a very old lady
so it goes for the 50's
and 60's, 70's and 80's.
I think when all is said and done,
probably a brandy and soda.
- Is that what you writing Emma?
Brandy and soda! I love it.
- Oh!
I love martinis too but
um, the drink I always
go back to, especially
when I'm weary, tired,
something like that.
- I like wine, I like a pinot noir what.
Um what's yours Emma?
What's your favorite drink?
- Oh boy well besides a
good strong cup of tea,
I like I like wine too,
I like Sauvignon Blanc. That's mine.
- Yeah, all right.
- I love tea.
- Okay last question,
what's the one time Julie
most embarrassed Emma
as a child or teenager?
Well there was lots of things I think.
- There weren't actually.
- hmm?
- there weren't actually lots of things.
- Okay.
- Okay let's see what y'all got.
- Go first Emma.
(laughs)
- There you go.
- [Kelly] Oh my god that's amazing.
- I happen to have a mouth as well,
my mother hates it.
- I knew there was something about you
I loved Kelly.
- Yeah its pretty bad.
Well I was a cocktail waitress
and dang-it just doesn't cover the gravity
of the emotion.
Anyways I just wanted
to say thank you so much
for taking the time.
I know that this is a weird time.
Alright y'all so Julie Andrews
and Emma Walton-Hamilton's
new podcast is called
Julie's library and it's
actually available tomorrow.
And be sure to watch Julie's
green room now on Netflix.